ajusta una recta a los datos o señala
que ninguna recta se acomoda bien a los
datos y bueno esencialmente lo que
queremos es una recta que al menos
muestre la tendencia de los datos así
que bueno aquí sí se ve claramente esta
tendencia por lo tanto si yo moviera
esta recta un poco como por acá y este
punto un poco como por acá para que la
recta se ajuste más o menos a estos
datos algo más o menos así bueno si te
das cuenta esta recta am se asemeja
bastante a la tendencia de estos datos
que tengo aquí gráfica 2 en estos puntos
de negro tengo el presentimiento de que
más o menos podemos ajustar esa
tendencia con esta recta y por lo tanto
las respuestas nos dicen se aplican
mueve la recta en la gráfica para
ajustarlas a los datos más o menos así
está bien y bueno la recta coincide con
los datos en la recta no coincide con
los datos y bueno voy a intentar
comprobar mi respuesta para ver si de
lujo estamos bien así que vamos a hacer
de ejercicios más fíjate bien en estos
datos yo lo que quiero hacer es ajustar
una recta a estos datos que tengo aquí
la podremos encontrar bueno pues parece
ser que tal vez si si yo a muevo esta
recta como por acá y esta recta como por
acá a algo más o menos así bueno pues
aquí creo que ya tengo una recta que nos
muestra un ajuste a la tendencia con
estos datos si te das cuenta todos estos
datos están más o menos a la misma
distancia que esta recta más o menos no
movería un poco por acá
y bueno entonces la recta cual sigue con
los datos y vamos a comprobar de nuevo
mi respuesta de lujo estamos bien así
que vamos a hacer un ejercicio más y
ahora tengo este ejercicio aquí y si te
das cuenta en este ejercicio no puedo
encontrar una recta que se ajuste a los
datos y no la puedo encontrar por la
siguiente razón si yo me acerco a estos
tres puntos si yo hago una recta más o
menos como por aquí bueno me estoy
acercando a estos tres puntos pero estos
puntos
no tiene nada que ver con la recta si
por ejemplo ignoramos estos puestos
puntos que tengo aquí bueno pues esta
recta más o menos es más la podemos
mover un poco más para acá sería una
recta que si ajusta a estos cuatro
puntos pero no podemos hacer eso ahora
si por ejemplo ignoramos estos cuatro
bueno pues yo podremos ver la recta
común por acá a algo así y decir bueno
esta recta más o menos me ajusta a estos
estos puntos que tengo aquí pero no
puedo ignorar datos no puedo ignorar
estos puntos por lo tanto voy a poner
que la respuesta es que no y vamos a
comprobar mi respuesta perfecto en este
caso no podíamos encontrar nuestra recta